clark county is crafting the look of its
upcoming what october memorial it'll be
built at the site of the route 91
harvest festival in the south end of the
strip nearly 5 200 people responded to a
recent input survey many felt mental
health education should be a significant
part of the memorial there's also a push
for stories that showcase heroism and
survival and artistically survey
responses want country music
incorporated into the memorial
the families will be worked with closely
to determine
what they're comfortable with what
holidays etc special events for momentos
to be placed
the memorial committee has said before
it will take a couple of years to build
the permanent facility or site i should
say the next meeting is set for
september 22nd
ahead of one october the vegas strong
resiliency center is putting out a
request for quilts the organization
hopes to collect 150 of them by
september 17th and then they'll be
raffled off to survivors of the shooting
during the upcoming anniversary weekend
if you would like to donate we have
information at eight newsnow dot com